after 11 grueling rounds in a three-way  tie going into the final day of the 2014  US Chess Championships champions have  emerged in the women's championships  Tata of Abraham Yan defeated honors at  own ski only to run into the two-time  defending champ arena crush who won the  match and proved once again why she's  such a formidable competitor this was  the hardest championship ever played you  know test teaches you to be to be a  fighter and in the men's Championships  version of Kobe on defeated Alexander  Linderman in the Armageddon match only  to run into defending champion gata  Kamsky who rolled to victory and proved  why he is a five-time champion it's  gonna look good on the resident for sure  congratulations to the 2014 US chess  champions arena crush and gotta calm ski  be sure to join us this August for more  exciting action at the Sinquefield Cup  here at the st. Louis chess club